the number of all possible values of
theta whereas data is between zero and
pi for which the systems of the system
of equations y plus Z cosine of 3 theta
plus XYZ sine of 3 theta X sine of 3
theta is equal to 2 cosine of 3 theta
over y plus 2 sine of 3 theta over Z X Y
Z sine of 3 theta is equal to y plus 2 Z
cosine of 3 theta plus y sine of 3 theta
has a solution X naught Y naught Z
naught with y naught Z naught e not
equaling zero is which just means either
of these cannot equal zero so this is a
pretty daunting thing and I just like to
simplify it as much as possible so what
I want to do is what I want to do two
things all of the trig functions here
are there all of they're taking sine or
the cosine of 3 theta and then have
theta between 0 and pi I want to do a
little substitution this is just for my
brain because it simplifies my logical a
little bit let's make a substitution
that U is equal to is equal to 3 theta
and then the U when theta is 0 U is
going to be so U is still going to be
greater than 0
and when theta is PI U is going to ask
going has to be less than 3 pi and so
this boils down to let's find the number
of views between 0 and 3 pi where y plus
Z cosine of U is equal to XYZ sine of u
so on and so forth so with that let's do
that substitution and also I'm going to
rearrange these so that they start to at
least look a little familiar and see if
we can somehow start start manipulating
with these equations and actually try to
cancel out terms so this first one up
here just to get into term ways that I
can recognize let me distribute the
cosine of 3 theta or which will now call
the cosine of U so let me just write
this this is you this is you this is you
now this is you you you you and you so
this if we distribute the cosine of U
this becomes cosine cosine of U let me
put the Y out front so it's Y cosine of
u plus Z cosine of U
is equal to X Y Z sine of U that's this
first equation this second equation this
second equation it looks like well if we
multiply both sides of this equation by
Y Z we're going to have an X Y Z sine of
U on the right hand side which is the
exact same thing we have here so let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
X Y Z by X Y Z both sides the right-hand
of the equation now not by X Y Z just by
Y Z so we're going to multiply both
sides of this equation by Y Z so that
these leave the denominator so we're
also going to multiply the right side by
Y Z the left-hand side becomes X Y Z
sine of U and let me write it over here
just right under this so this is X Y Z
sine of U and then Y Z times 2 cosine of
U is going to be 2 Z cosine of U so 2 Z
cosine of U I just swapped the sides and
then Y Z times 2 sine of U is going to
be 2 y sine of u so 2 2 y 2 y sine of U
so this is the second equation and now
they don't look that different when
they're written like this they look very
different now let's think about this one
this has an X Y Z sine of U I lit in
magenta this equation X Y Z sine of u
I'll write it on this side x Y Z sine of
u is equal to is equal to let's see we
have a 2 Z let's distribute this cosine
of U we have a 2 Z cosine of u so plus 2
Z cosine 2 Z cosine of u plus y cosine
of U so we have a plus y Y cosine of u
that's that times that plus y sine of U
so let me scroll to the right little
left a little bit Y sine of U so I've
rewritten these three equations the
problem looks a lot less daunting right
now let's try to figure out let's try to
figure out the
number of yous between zero and three pi
that will satisfy that will give us a
solution here so let's see all of these
three equations are equal to this
expression right over here so the
left-hand sides the left-hand sides of
these equations all have to equal each
other because they all equal the exact
same value so let's do that let's see
what what we can do in the way of
canceling in the way of canceling things
out let's see if we use let me this is a
plus right here I don't know why we
wrote an equal here so let's see if we
write this has got to be equal to that
so let me use these two two first so
this thing so we have two Y two Y sine
sine of U plus two Z cosine of U is
equal to this which is that which is has
to be equal to this is going to be equal
to Y sine of U plus y cosine of u plus
two Z cosine plus two Z cosine of U we
have to Z cosine of U on both sides so
that gets rid of the Z terms and then we
have 2y sine of u and we have a Y sine
of U so if we subtract Y sine of u from
both sides we end up with a Y sine of U
Y sine of u just subtracting this from
both sides two Y minus y sine of you're
just going to be Y sine of u is equal to
Y is equal to Y cosine of U so in order
for this in order to have a solution
here in order for this to be a sensical
statement and remember y cannot be equal
to zero in order for this to end up
having a solution this the code the
coefficients on Y have to equal each
other sine of U has to be equal to sine
of U has to be equal to cosine of U so
that's one constraint sine of U has to
be equal to cosine of U and let's just
think about the unit circle and think
about how many times are the sign and
the
cosine equal to each other when you're
going between zero and three pi so I got
the unit circle right right over here
now clearly when we're at 45 degrees
sine and cosine are equal to each other
or 45 degrees is the same thing as PI
over 4 we're at that they're they're
equal to each other you might be tempted
to do this over here but here the cosine
is negative sine is positive so that
won't work they're both negative over
here but they're equal so that's another
value and then this won't work so so far
we've traveled to PI we can go another
1/2 we can go 3 PI so we can go back to
this one again so we can go back to this
value again so there are one two and
then when you go all the way around
again three values and then we can't go
back to this one because we can only go
let me just in another color we can only
go three pi for you so we can only go
that's two pi and then go another time
around that is three pi so there's one
two three values so there's three three
possible possible use just from this
constraint just when we use this blue
equation and this magenta equation now
let's just let's just make sure let's
just make sure that there aren't any
further that there aren't any further
constraints over here so let's see if we
can let's use two of the other equations
and the ones that I would want to use
that seems like there might be some
cancellation well we could just use
really could use we could use either
this guy and this guy Y cosine of U plus
2 Z yeah why not so let's use so as long
as we're using all three equations in
our constraints we will have kind of
properly constrained all of the possible
solutions and so let's think about it
this this this equals that which is
equal to that which is equal to that so
we could write Y cosine of U Y cosine of
U plus Z cosine of U is equal to this
whole thing over here is equal to Y sine
of U
two plus y cosine of U plus two Z - Z
cosine of U and then we have a Y cosine
of U on both sides so those will cancel
out we can subtract a Z cosine of U from
both sides z cosine of U from both sides
and so we would get zero is equal to Y
sine of U plus Z cosine plus Z cosine of
U and this seems like a pretty like a
pretty benign statement y sine of u plus
Z cosine of U is equal to zero well let
me make sure that see Y sine of u plus Z
cosine of U is equal to zero that means
that this is means that two times this
is also going to be zero so this is
equal to 2y sine of u plus two Z cosine
of U is equal to zero and the only
reason why I multiplied it by two is
because then now this looks identical to
this so the way I used this equation and
this equation I got a constraint that
this expression right over here this
expression right over here essentially
needs to be equal to zero
that this expression over here
essentially needs to be equal to zero
which is okay which is okay because you
could make the sine equal to zero or X
can be equal to zero remember they
didn't put any constrains on X X can be
equal to zero so this is really
constraining us X can clearly be equal
to zero which could make this thing
equal to zero so it's not a it's not
limiting our constraints so now we've
used all of the information that's in
the problem we've used all three of
these surfaces essentially to find out
if there's an inter what what are the
constraints we have for an intersection
of the three surfaces and the only real
constraint is that the sine of U has to
be equal to the cosine of U and there
are three possible use between 0 & 3 pi
that satisfy that